no that's the dot is this true this is a
true story this is
facts
oh okay welcome welcome
welcome all to the 157th edition
of sng i am your co-host
jimmy j um aka j money aka
uh junior trees aka romy my peasy's aka
sng hosties and i'm uh accompanied by my
fellow co-host mr i am mr fuego
mr f money mr fuhad mr forte
wherever you want to call me the f's
around me
yeah man so um let's cut to the chase
people patreon is moving fast
faster than we ever anticipated the
exponential growth rather the
exponential food i love to say the
exponentials
they're scaring us now and we can't keep
up with this level of p
so we need so let's just
say this i was born with a mindset they
say you know actually no no they would
pull up
there's a theory right there's a theory
that like
um you know did i i've told you this
before that like there's such a high
percentage of people
that there's a high percentage of people
that when they win the lottery
or come into like excessive amounts of
money you'll find within the first year
or two they're back to square one yeah
uh and i've learned a little bit about
the psychology behind it and a lot of
people psychologically
don't feel like they deserve money
because of the negative connotations
about money
a lot of people actually psychology feel
like they don't deserve
money um because everything you talk
about money is
always negative so it's always like
money can't buy you happiness
or um you're not supposed to discuss
like asking for a raise is like a big
deal yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and just anything
around money or talking about your own
money or how much money you make like
that has a real bad connotations to it
so negative people have a real negative
aspect when it comes to money when
they're
gifted a lot of money and and they
haven't mentally prepared themselves for
that level of money
they'll find a subconscious way to get
rid of it as fast as they can oh
and they'll they'll be they'll be
flatbread a lot of people when they're
in the lottery their flat broke within
like a year or two
that's spunky should not be me boy bro
it wouldn't be me but
that's what i'm saying so you lot
need to influx more p so that i can
mentally prepare myself for this yeah
yeah influx so i can get myself ready to
be rich
because i don't want to be back to
square one we can't be back we've got no
choice
this is it this is literally do or die
and if you don't want us to die
you know what to do this is um speaking
of the office yeah do you see the one
where
uh michael um
michael wanted to put meredith in um
rehab yeah she's an alcoholic yes and
then
when he took her there is oh it turns
out you can't forcibly put someone into
rehab
yeah they have to like they have to be
okay with they have to check themselves
in and check themselves
she's like oh she just needs to hit rock
bottom before she can go to rehab so
i'm gonna make sure i'm gonna have to
help her to hit rock bottom that's
basically what you are to us you need to
help us reach our goals yeah help us
reach out
i'm at right bottom check me into rehab
run
us to pee real quick real quick please
it's not it's not that hard
it's not that hard yeah it's actually
simple so yeah just while we've been
started this episode i've already seen
like three new patrons so gang gang for
you man
um and yeah obviously guys uh if you're
watching us on the videos
like the videos comment uh subscribe and
guys with the audio if you love the the
mellow smooth jazz voices that you're
hearing in your ear um
subscribers and everything's there as
well um only fans is popping
um i've just been dabbling in like kind
of nipple stuff
so far nothing to raunch i'm just
letting the audience build before
yeah yeah release the beast and that's
it before you show them full chat yeah
yeah
forest full chest it's just little nip
slips and uh yeah yeah
we married for that so obviously i know
that's you man do you mind you and men
are the only ones that i know about
speaking of oh god random obviously i
spoke about starting to know your fans
for clarity obviously i don't have an
only phone for clarity obviously i don't
have an only fans
one donny at work messaged me at work
the other day i'm just i'm just chilling
i get a message just on microsoft
teams fam just team's message i'm like
what's that
one done from work like how's the new
career path going i was like what's that
new career path i thought it was talked
about the pod yeah yeah and i was
thinking
this is going to be an awkward
conversation and i was like new career
path and he's like yeah only fans how's
that going
and i was like because obviously just
because i said on here yeah yeah and i
was like
it's going well it's going well thank
you for asking
it's live if you want to collab
let me know for the link these men are
always looking for fresh meat uh
you need a collapsing let me know i'll
show you the ropes
but yeah man so uh guys obviously thank
you as usual
and uh without any further ado let's
jump into the epp yeah with a fun fact
fun fact of the day um
so did you know that dogs likely dogs
like squeaky toys for dark reasons
so do you ever wonder why little puppies
over they overly obsessed with squeaky
toys
is because they are descendants of
wolves whose instincts include hunting
small animals
the sound of a squeaky toy makes a very
similar sound to a small animal when
it's been hunted
jesus christ that makes perfect as soon
as you said have you ever wondered why
dogs like squeaky toys
i immediately knew what you were going
to say it sounds like a [ __ ] dying
rabbit or something
i can't even mimic the sound yeah boy oh
wow yeah mum that's crazy
that is crazy that is very crazy oh god
that is very jesus christ speaking of
dark
um obviously we spoke on the previous
episode about
uh the night stalker so yeah i binge
watched it yesterday
i binge watched the whole thing
yesterday and it's
fantastic the whole documentary itself
is fantastic isn't it just great
it's so great but it's it's mind-blowing
how
he got away with this for like 170 days
or whatever like he was dumping people
left right and center firm i'm glad
obviously i don't need to spoil it for
you now yeah these men have had
a week now to watch it or two i can't
remember how long ago it was
they've had enough time to watch it so
let's talk let's talk they've had enough
time to watch it
so i don't care anything it's your fault
if you know if you haven't caught it
it's your [ __ ] fault if you haven't
caught up pause this and watch the first
episode
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cool so yeah
um might when when um
these fumbled the footprinting when the
mayor
was like ah the police are working
against it because
they've got all this evidence yeah she
reeled off all the evidence all the
evidence we know that he wears this shoe
you know a 12
size 12 size character yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah one
one in the making there's literally that
one player in l.a
he has the only one pair of shoes also
how weird is that
when he said that i was thinking is that
true i mean what are the odds what
what are the odds what the odds are the
only piece of evidence that you guys
have got for a serial killer happens to
be that he purchased
the only pair of black this type of shoe
in the whole city of los angeles it was
very coincidental that's [ __ ]
coincidental
even though it didn't help them
whatsoever whatsoever at the end of the
day but you know two things that
actually spun me
um when when um
the main the main detector i think his
name is carrillo or something like a
current
yeah the mexican yeah yeah um he was
talking about how
um the mind man was six minutes down the
road from him
and then new killing was six minutes
down the road from him and his wife and
his kids were like
as if he's this close i'm leaving and
i'm not coming back until that happens
yeah yeah yeah obviously you complete
when you watch documentaries like this
you completely forget
how it affects the actual people that
are trying to find these actual
criminals bro like the families and
stuff like
when the wife was talking and stuff it
made me feel like these are actually
going through stuff
and they don't realize the magnitude of
what the pressure the husband's on
because the husband needs to find these
guys he said i need my wife at home i
have my wife at home but i also need my
wife safe the same way she needs to dip
but she also has yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man didn't
see these kids for time time three kids
just bopped out to that wedding at the
end of it never was like
where's my wife
i just want to see my wife and i'm like
oh my god
i feel you bro bro tough it's mad
it's mine another thing i just got off
another thing that made me think wow
this is
well written is because obviously in
documentaries you never hear
the interviewer asking the questions but
every question must be
written out perfectly because the
answers they have to the answers after
you get obviously have to be edited in a
way that it looks
interesting but how do you even come up
with the questions in the first place
like
i want to be in the the thinking room of
all these writers yeah yeah yeah because
the way that they think
yeah the way they think is incredible
because the way they patterned the story
the way they got this person and that
person that person is just like
oh my god and the first time he went
across state from
i think downtown the later years san
francisco and they've done the first
murder and he baited out the whole thing
that's when he said they may have baited
out the whole thing
and when the uh the newscasters clocked
them on the plane
when the two newscasters clocked them on
the plane and then
one of the miamis actually spoke to the
killer do you remember
no fam you didn't see that you don't
remember that bit i know they clocked
them on the plane
no no no so the the two um
the two police officers and the two news
reporters that were chasing up on the
clues that they had
went on the same plane to another city
because they had a they had a tip that
he had moved to another city because
there was a killing there
obviously the news reporters didn't get
the tip from the police officers just
heard it around town yeah
so when the um newspapers got they i
think the newsport reporters got to
the house before the police officers
yeah yeah yeah and they spoke to the guy
that was a guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a guy
watching his car and he said something
along the lines of oh
the markings on the wall which had never
been released to the press so obviously
he had to be
had to open my man do you not think no
it wasn't him
no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's not happened
so that is what happened yeah but the
guy knows the markings on the wall
because all the police know that uh but
the reporters don't know that okay
they intentionally okay the police
basically buried that evidence yeah yeah
didn't let the media know that okay
because he said he said because
once devil worship gets into into these
man's brain they're gonna lose it
okay because obviously he said when they
ask him oh what do you do they said i'm
a police officer i thought it was the
killer pretending no no no no
it was an actual police officer talking
and he didn't that police officer
because it's in a different city
didn't know he wasn't allowed to talk
about the market he said we know it's
him because of the markets on the wall
and then donnie was like is on the wall
you've never heard nothing about him
and that's when civilians were like it's
not safe
he's a devil worshiper episode 3 when
they um
actually revealed his face his eyes bro
dead scared black and dead
christ out bro he's a scary guy he's a
huge looking guy he's tall and big as
well
he was lean fam do you remember and
obviously when the uh when he went to
court he had
fans of females bro that's what i was
going to say i actually written my notes
when i was going to talk about the
nightstalker
i knew for a fact as soon as he got
arrested as soon as he got arrested
um and obviously you know when they said
ah the whole community came together
yeah and uh they were all like rallying
around and having like parades and stuff
like that about his arrest
i said out loud obviously to myself i
said
guaranteed this [ __ ] gets nudes
in jail
i bet some [ __ ] are just crazy for
serial killers
i don't know what it is they're crazy
there's always these guys on death row
that are just getting nudes and they get
married like
to their pen pals or just chicks up in
there same thing happened to um
ted bundy have you seen i've not it i've
never seen a documentary but i've heard
this
bro one yeah was on him on him
and he was banging her i'm pretty sure
it was his lawyer was his lawyer
it might have been his lawyer he was
banging he was banging someone else as
well but he was banging his lawyer oh
wow
um banging wow from something about
this this like i don't know if it's a
power thing or
bro something about his killer intent
these hoes were dripping he was getting
news
news i remember nudes
galore bro that was down great show guys
you definitely yeah yeah yeah that was
so much a nice story that was sick
all right convince you now then i guess
we can't convince you anymore bro
can't be helped um yeah i've got a
theory a fan theory oh gang
this one's saucy this one's saucy
it takes a family movie into
into a psychological thriller oh
everyone's seen them
okay the ones i've only picked ones that
i know you've seen
okay because there was like there's like
star wars ones out there but i'm like
he's not going to give a [ __ ] yeah yeah
i've only seen like the new age star
wars i've never seen the old ones oh
okay cool
right so this theory is
nemo so finding nemo okay the film's
fine nemo nemo
was an imaginary device you know about
this one i've heard this but read it
i know exactly what it is okay cool so
nemo was an imaginary device for marlin
to come to terms with his wife's death
this is juicy this is juicy
so in latin nemo translates to no one
this helps spur the theory that marlin's
son doesn't actually exist in finding
nemo
but isn't it's an invention he uses in
order to come to terms
with the death of his wife we see marlin
go through the five stages of grief in
the film
first denial when he invents nemo's egg
after the rest of his family are killed
second is anger as he freaks out
whenever nemo is too far from him
third bargaining as he convinces dory to
join his quest
and then puts up with her fourth is
despair when he sees nemo flush down the
toilet
and finally is acceptance as he's able
to let go of nemo um
let nemo go off on on his own in the end
crazy bro when i when i read that i
can't remember where and when i read it
but i've read that one before
i was crazy bro wow that's twisted
that's very twisted for them to if that
is true
for them to put that in a disney movie
and just leave it as like an undertone
thing for no one to probably clock
fam that's very dark ting didn't exist
at all that's very varied it's like the
sixth sense
that's very dark do you remember the
first time you saw the sixth sense no
i don't you don't no so you don't
remember the first feeling when you were
just like
he's dead i've
if i'm being honest i've probably not
seen it i've probably not seen it
i knew you were going to make that face
but i've probably not seen it because
for you to say that
it must it must mean that if i've seen
it i would remember i've seen something
do not mean you know what six sentences
about
i've not seen that [ __ ] i've not seen
it [ __ ] hell tell me hit me
do you know what it is well like this
sixth sense like like the
like an alternate dimension kind of
thing like um
if you're dead you're not dead and blah
blah all that kind of thing like
obviously you've got five sentences but
the sixth sense is something more
yeah no i'm not asking i'm not saying do
you know what the film is like
i've seen the movie cool so when i said
do you remember the first time you
watched the sixth sense
and you said no no because i was
thinking have i seen the movie oh okay
all right cool
cool cool if you can't i can't if i had
seen a movie i probably won't remember
the first time i've seen the movie all
right first play all right
cool i'm gonna spoil this whole movie it
doesn't matter the movie's like 30 years
old
it's banging okay the sixth sense right
with uh bruce willis
and that weird kid that's in like ai
have seen ai no but i know that i know
that you know the
net is that on netflix
else is this kid in he's in six senses
in ai he's also um do you remember that
right cool do you remember the fat son
in the entourage movie you've seen the
entourage movie yes my family was years
ago
the entourage revealed that many years
ago it is it's quite a while ago it's a
few years ago there's not that many
years ago
i've never seen that movie once bro i
[ __ ] haven't got to google it just
keep talking right yeah google the sixth
sense
jesus christ you're finding out all
these characters i can't remember
right cool so he is a kid who sees dead
people
okay and bruce willis is a therapist who
obviously doesn't believe that this kid
can see dead people
he just thinks the kid is traumatized
he's a child therapist he just thinks
the kid's traumatized
okay um and he's basically working as a
therapist
to um understand what what his childhood
issues are and all this all this all
this
um and um
he goes through the whole process uh
with him finding out and the more time
he spends with him
the more he realizes that [ __ ] i think
this kid can actually see [ __ ] dead
people i've clocked that
by the way yeah yeah yeah it looks very
familiar so he's i think this kid can
actually see dead people because he's
just going through
all these processes he goes to a funeral
of a girl and he speaks to the girls
ghosts and stuff like that and he
understands what
actually happened to the girl to make
her die and he's obviously telling bruce
willis and bruce was just [ __ ] hell
like how else would you possibly know
that yeah he can actually [ __ ] talk
to dead people
so he's going through go through going
through and he remembers a time
of an old client he had back in the day
back in the day who said the same thing
he can see dead people
but obviously he never paid much
attention to it he just obviously gave
him drugs and all this stuff and
he wouldn't he never truly helped him
and that was the one uh
kid that he never ever ever ever truly
helps and obviously at the start of that
movie
you find that kid is an adult now he
breaks into bruce willis house
with a gun i said you never helped me
you know that but you don't know
anything about this guy
oh you don't know any because it's the
first scene in the movie so he breaks in
he's like shirtless and stuff and he's
skinny and he's shaking and crying so
you never [ __ ] help me
i came to you and he did you and you
weren't there for me and he's like bro
calm down
calm the [ __ ] down i don't know yeah
he's like it's cool
let's talk about it and he shoots him
shoots him down here yeah shoots him
[ __ ] runs off
um and um so
the first scene is literally bruce
willis getting shot
and he's like hip or whatever come this
[ __ ] crazy guy and later on down the
line
he starts going through his old um
cassette tapes and stuff off his
interviews with this kid okay back in
the day
okay um talking about he can see dead
people and stuff like that and he's
thinking [ __ ]
this is the same thing this is the same
thing that [ __ ]
little my man's going through now and
i'm starting to believe my man
maybe i should have believed my man from
the jump from the jump and he wouldn't
have grown up to be a [ __ ] crazy
person breaking in my house
maybe he's right maybe i didn't [ __ ]
help him yeah maybe i should have
listened to him instead of thinking he
was crazy maybe he actually could
see [ __ ] dead people yeah and he
starts going through
all the process of like what david um
not david david's david's the kid's name
in ai which is annoying
the kids who can see dead people um
bruce willis is talking like how do you
know when like a dead person's knee or
stuff like that he's talking
about it it gets cold um cole is his
name
cole yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i saw you
like oh cole like how do you know you
can see dead people and stuff like that
yeah
it gets colder when they're around and
like um
they don't know they're dead so they'll
talk to you and they think they're alive
so they don't understand why people you
you're
like i'm scared of them and stuff like
that they don't know they're dead
uh and it's obviously cold and they
invent reasons why people are ignoring
them
and um in their head just to cope with
the fact that people no one can see them
but me and stuff like that
i go for it go for it go for it and as
bruce willis is [ __ ]
uh listening to his old tapes of
listening to the kid who broke into his
house when he was
shot him he's realizing more and more
things about similarities between what
they're saying
fam push comes to shove and he's
thinking about [ __ ] that's going on his
own life because he's going for a
divorce of his wife
his device [ __ ] basically lives in
like they live in the same house but
they live separate completely separate
right throughout the movie every time
he's in the house with his wife wife to
pay no attention to him and stuff like
that
he's going through like a bad time with
his wife okay so we start thinking
thinking thinking thinking fam
bruce willis is dead that's the end of
the movie
bruce willis is dead he's been dead the
whole time when donnie came into his
yard and shot him
killed him killed him bruce willis
invented a situation in his head where
he healed from the bullet wound
and he's going through this trauma with
his wife he ain't going through no
trouble his wife don't know he's there
no way so all these times he's in the
air talking to his wife and his wife
ignoring him he thinks he's having
issues with his wife fam
wife don't know he's alive he's dead
he's a ghost
he goes into the scenes where he goes
into the bedroom to see his wife and
give her a kiss
and she's like shaking and she's blowing
like obviously you can see the
the breath coming out of her and he's
just thinking [ __ ] sake and he just
puts a blanket on her
he goes to sleep in the [ __ ] basement
or something because he thinks he's
having trouble with his wife
oh mad and he's a and he's having his
interviews to be a therapist for cole
and he's [ __ ] dead the only reason
cole's the person that talks to him is
because he's [ __ ] dead
because he can see that people because
he can see if i can dear people mad
the sixth sense bro such a six such a
sick film
such a sick film i don't know how we
even got onto it what were we talking
about before
finding nemo psychological mechanisms to
coping mechanisms and stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah sixth sense yeah finding
nemo is like the success
marlin is bruce willis cool that's
that's how we've tied this all together
no i get lost in thought sometimes i can
tell you that
i'm so disappointed you haven't seen the
success i know because it's such an old
film there's no point watching them now
but from the first time you watch the
sixth sense and when you realize bruce
willis is dead
you're just like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you just don't know yeah like you have
to be
if you're good enough to realize that
he's dead at the beginning of the film
you're the only one that loses out yeah
do you know what i mean true true true
because you wouldn't enjoy it as much
yeah
because the the twist is just like oh
[ __ ]
it reminds me of a movie have you seen
fractured on netflix it's the same
guy that um did avatar the main
character
the comrade's name loses his wife his
wife and child or something or his child
is based in a hospital for most of it
yes yeah i've seen it i've seen it
yeah it's similar to that with a similar
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he killed all right he killed his um his
uh
daughter drops and then he killed his
wife by mistake
yeah and he just invents his whole thing
to cope with it whole
up bro the whole thing in yourself
that's real [ __ ] you know
people do that wow when they can't
accept that's like um
on um i am a killer
okay i still need to start that it's
okay
it's okay it's it's it's okay don't
don't rush to watch it right now it's
okay i wanna watch the seasonal hotel
one yeah
yeah yeah i need to watch a hotel one as
well so
he um in i'm a killer there's it
basically just interviews killers
okay who are actually in prison right
now
and um there's one guy who he was a
crackhead
and killed his nan jesus fam
brutally with a baseball bat oh my god
so basically he's a crackhead he already
shot his dad went to prison came out of
prison
um and was living with nan all he used
to do every day was just do coke
crack heroin anything he was just a
druggie his whole day fam
he was bored his whole day was drugs so
he'd always ask his nan for money give
me money give him one he was spending
300
a day on drugs he was an addict fam an
addict 300
a day what are you what can you fam
ingest with i don't know it's a lot it's
a lot that's a lot of money if i'm human
as boys used to just sit in one attic
and just
do drugs all day how did you not die
[ __ ] those he's tolerance is higher
his terrorist is [ __ ] high geez so
he'd ask her for money money money and
one day she was like nah i'm giving you
nothing
so he was like i'm gonna rob this [ __ ]
he's got a crackhead mentality he's like
i'll rob you for him he said it to her
face nah but he just said he was like
nan please knees please like come on i
need peaches she's like
i'm not giving you anything i give you
money every day you don't have a job you
don't do anything you live here for free
and all you do is drinks my pee i give
you money every day enough is enough
like you've already been in and out of
pen like make something of your life i'm
not an enabler out here because
you're not getting another penny out of
me it's all right cool cool what's into
the kitchen side i need to
i need to rob this [ __ ] that's what he
just his immediate thoughts i need to
rub this [ __ ]
i need the p now i need the p
right now i got time for games so
man was um going through her purse or
whatever
and she caught him she was like stop
stop grabbed her purse and stuff
and i was like alright cool grips the
baseball bat
and tumped her run the back of the head
as soon as he taught her he said the
first thing that came to his head was
i need to kill this [ __ ] now i'm
already this far in
i need to kill her now i don't know why
that was his mentality but his mentality
was i need to kill her now
so he bludgeoned her to death with a
baseball bat and tied her to the bed i
don't know if he started before or after
but he tied her to the bed and beat the
[ __ ] out until she died then took the p
so he did a runner eventually he got
caught by the police and stuff
and his immediate thing was i didn't do
it i didn't do it he blamed it on one of
his boys
and said jackson did it jackson was just
like
his name's actually jackson but first
thing i came to my head jackson had an
alibi family yeah batman were like
nah he was with us yeah jackson was like
big man i was with these but everyone
was like he was with us he was in public
ah mama flopped flopped it immediately
fam
he went through the whole process like
court trial
everything fam prison got put on death
row the whole time
even years and years into it five six
seven years into pen mazar jackson did
it i didn't do it i shouldn't be here
jackson did it he'd convinced himself in
his head that jackson had done it
he couldn't face the reality of what he
actually done so his coping mechanism
was to actually believe his own lie
and say that jackson did it jackson did
jackson they did but me jackson did it
they had this therapy class where you
have to own up to what you've done
and speak about it and speak about how
it makes you feel and how do you feel
about the people that you've affected
but the crime that you've done and stuff
like that
and every week he used to go there uh no
he never used to go and one of his his
cellmate used to go
every day and he kept saying somebody
said come you need to come you need to
come he's a big man what do i need to
come for
i didn't do it i'm innocent so why am i
coming he's all right cool
we go by two weeks three weeks and then
one day donny turns to his uh cell mate
and says
i want to come today and don't swear
okay yeah i'm gonna go today i'm gonna
go to a circle time whatever the [ __ ]
they call it i'm gonna go circle time
today
some man said i'm coming i need to see
this
i'm coming i don't know what you want to
come for mr edison i don't know why you
want to roll
sam man sat down in the thing and we're
like cool we got a new guy here today
xyz stand up and tell us tell us about
yourself
it's a flat um cellmate's just sitting
there like i don't know what he's gonna
do i don't know what he's here for yeah
man said cool my name is david and um i
killed my grandmother
it's the first time he'd ever said it
he'd been there for years for him
oh wow the first [ __ ] time he'd ever
said wow
first time and ever since then he he
said
a weight lifted off his shoulders
imagine he was like bruv i did it i'm
kidding
i'm opening up to it now this is me i'm
a murderer it reminds me of one that i
watched not too long ago it was just
like a
a one ep special thing um where
i'm trying to find the name that's why
i'm looking on netflix now i'm trying to
find the name of what it's called
which is going to annoy me if i can't
find it okay it's about a it's about a
family
um a guy has a wife who is
i think she's terminally ill or she's
got cancer maybe and she's got two
daughters and they're about to have
another kid
um but there's one time he just comes
back home one day now she
she comes back home from um like a
work do with her friend this was um
let's say it was in
california but she lives in los angeles
another city for example she came back
one day
and she came out at home at like 2 a.m
the husband went out for work at let's
say 6 a.m
um and on his way back home
the friend was calling the friend that
she went on for this work thing for was
calling
the friend's phone saying oh where are
you are you blah blah because they had a
meeting the next day or something
um she didn't answer her phone she was
calling the husband husband's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on
they both came home noticed that there
was no one in the yard
they had the dog so the dog was barking
barking barking um walked into the yard
because obviously the husband came back
home
they got the police there and everything
was everything was the same
but she was not there but her phone was
there and her wedding ring was there
um so just thinking the obviously the
husband the police the friend the friend
son was thinking what the [ __ ] is going
on like what the actual [ __ ] going on
like this
this isn't her normal behavior etc it's
and the police are you having troubles
in your
relationship blah blah he's like no like
we've been we've been blessed for time
we've been blessed with time
etc they went to the neighbor's yard
because he's got a camera
that faces like their garage or
something like that um and
he was like oh let me let me have a look
at what's going on they had a look now
um all this all you see is i like 4 am a
car pull up
and a car leave that's it but i think it
was his truck because he he comes and
goes like
um early hours and late nights because
he works in like an oil rig kind of
thing
um but as soon as the husband left
the police officer stayed to just keep
checking more stuff and the guy that was
housing like he's acting [ __ ] weird
he's acting [ __ ] he never acts like
this this is very weird i'm like
okay so they this was like episodes this
is like early in episode rob because
only one episode is like one hour and 20
minutes or something like that
this is early in the episode okay i'll
take my information etc
and then it starts to go back obviously
you know how it goes back and forth back
and forth in these kind of like timeline
wise
um so it starts to go back as to when
they went to meet with
the husband's parents because the kids
were close to the husband's grandparents
um but they they didn't know that what
they knew that one of the daughters has
an allergy but
they weren't taking care of that allergy
in terms of like let's say for example
she had a peanut allergy
they would they would put peanuts all
over the place and that kind of thing
they
and the wife was getting so vectors like
you're never going to see my kid my kids
again if you stop doing this
and he messaged her husband because the
husband was in in the yard while
they went to meet the grandparents in a
different city um
but he would the way he was replying was
so dead like very bland all the utc
and she was like she was texting her
bridge and saying oh i've not [ __ ] my
husband in
three weeks or four weeks blah blah blah
and it's like what the [ __ ] going on
what the [ __ ] is going on kind of thing
and they were saying oh do you think
he'd be cheating on you he's like no
he just doesn't seem the kind of type
but this guy was big before
this guy was big before and then you'd
notice throughout the show that
he's banging weights now he's looking
shredded he's looking good he's looking
good
and then it comes to a point where they
she's been missing for let's say she's
been missing for 20 days for example
and then obviously everyone's
questioning and they obviously take the
they take the husband in for questioning
because most likely the husband will
know something yeah
you know and they do a lie detector test
on him
um and the first first questions are um
did you did you um what do you remember
the last time you saw your wife
and he says the right answer kind of
thing and remember the last time you saw
your kids
um have you been involved in your wife
or kid's disappearance
blah blah blah what were you doing here
just to get like a general basis of it
um and then i think the next day they're
calling back into the things like
sorry sorry sorry before the actual um
before the actual lie detector
they ask him they say to him just so you
know
there is no point in lying in this
because we will find out the truth
there's no point at some point don't
scare me there's no point at all
because we will find that to do so i
just want you to be prepared for this
obviously i know you're the husband i
know you're a bit disheveled with
the stuff's going on in your family but
just to let you know there's no way you
can escape this
and then they ask them these questions
they know what they're doing yeah so he
came back the next day
um so it was him the one that conducted
the into um the lie detector interview
and another officer
sat him down and just said point at flat
out black like
we know you lied in the in the um in the
lie detector we know you lied
so just tell us what happened just tell
us what happened obviously this guy is
like he's taking her back he's still
saying
i didn't do anything i don't know where
she is blah blah blah i want my wife i
want my kids
but she says to him throughout this
whole thing
not once have you cried not once have
you no throughout this whole thing he's
not asked by his kids
he only asked about his wife he never
asked about his kids um
and then the other officer that joined
them was like oh
were you having an affair i was like no
i'd never cheat on my wife no i never
cheated my wife
and he said because we noticed you were
like let's say 200 pounds before and now
you got 150
because man is man shredded now and
that's usually influenced by another
female party
he's like no i've never cheated more i
know i never cheat my wife and he's like
okay
we're gonna leave and he said he asked
oh can i speak to my dad because his dad
was there with him so they
left and then he and the pops came in
and said they were talking obviously the
cameras were on
and obviously they put everything in
subtitles like the pop's points having
the show is like tell me what's going on
what is actually going on
and he put his hand in his head like
i [ __ ] killed her and the dad was
like
what what and he was he said something
along the lines of
um he blamed he blamed the reason why he
killed her because of the kids like
maybe she was taking the kids away from
him or something something something
something like that and then so where
the [ __ ] are the kids
hold on i'm on edge hold on hold on hold
on he was like ah
but um how did it happen kind of thing
it's like
uh there were argument argument arguing
and then he i think the next day
or something he suffocated her that's
what he said to her that's what he said
to the father rather
and i was like okay bet because
obviously in previous in previous um
and during the previous days he was on
the media saying oh
i can't find my wife please help me find
one like it was statewide it was
statewide it was a big take
um but it turns out that when he finally
confessed
he obviously killed his wife um and then
when when i said to you um the neighbor
saying that this brain was acting funny
and he saw her in the
in his camera that oh he was driving at
4am or whatever
he had wrapped up his wife's body put
her in the boot
took the kids drove to the oil rig that
he worked at
buried his wife in one random bit of the
oil rig
and then obviously the kids were like
what's going on what's going on where's
mommy where's my mommy's like don't
worry she's fine she's five she's fine
took the kids up to the oil rig opened
it
and they looked at each other and said
daddy what are you doing pushing her in
push them both in no both in no
and he said the last thing he heard was
his kid screaming and then a loud like
collision and he closed up and that was
he had done that
the day of the beginning of the episode
when i say the beginning of the episode
is
her coming back from the the thing
i come back from thing with her friend
and then the next day it shows
that no one's in the yard and the
husband's coming back from work because
the bridges called and said i can't find
my friend
i can't find your wife yeah so he done
it that morning
and it goes through the whole thing to
find out how he did it he found out so
he'd already done it he'd already done
it and come home
knowing where the ring was because he
put the ring there knowing that the
phone was in the yard because he put the
phone there
and left everything as it was but you
won't realize it until yet like he
didn't
speak obviously when it came to the the
trial and stuff he wasn't saying
anything it was just there
shaking and crying shaking and crying
because he couldn't believe what you're
done
he couldn't believe it pushed his
[ __ ] kids in an oil rig
pushed him no that's the dot is this
true
this is a true story this is facts
this i can't remember that's an oscar
winning story that can't have happened i
need to find out where it's called oh
it's that's why i'm saying i'm i'm
looking up watched again but i can't
find it
wow i've never heard of this thing oh
i think you would have g i might have
heard the name when you say it
oh it's so annoying that i can't find it
let me google [ __ ]
dad pushes kids pushes
kids it was like a one-off foil rig
netflix i bet that comes up
it was a one-off um netflix series or
netflix special kind of thing
chris what's wife before murders fuzz
and body and oil tanks
what's that called chris watts netflix
murder documentary
family killer is always called yes
family killer yes
cool yes yes yes yes yes
jesus christ bro that's insane
yeah it's um it's it's not called it's
not kosher it wasn't go
that's insane bro that's insane
no no no it's not good family killer i
found it sorry it's called american
murder the family next door
okay american murder the family next
door wow
that's a great documentary great
obviously i support the whole thing
that's fine it's a great documentary
that's the thing like i don't
if you're gonna give me as detailed uh
thing like that i experienced it
yeah without having to watch it yeah
yeah yeah you don't need to watch it
like i don't have to see it from the
horse's mouth
to get the same like [ __ ] hell as
long as you can build it up correctly
if you would have been like bro there's
a netflix documentary one don [ __ ]
kill was his wife buries her and then
pushes his kids in the oil rig
it was mad and just left it out living
i would have been livid that's crazy bro
yeah it's mad stuff where people kill
their like family
it's tapped bro because it reminded me
when you said uh the guy killed his nun
yeah it reminded me of that i was
thinking yeah bro
some of that stuff is is is out of
control
very very dark out of control this will
step from your fan theory thing
nemo i can find the nemo thing yeah yeah
marlin seems like one of those guys as
well
he does seem like one of those dons bro
when son
i always think well i hate these these
kind of stories i'm thinking i'm
thinking
what could possibly happen for me to
snap like that
to snap like that where i'm willing to
just black out and kill my kids can my
wife kill
everyone because with these kids it's
annoying because
his wife was probably out of anger his
kids was pre-meditated man had to drive
to the spot
to duppy off his kids mm-hmm and she's
like how
that's what i said two years a day in
here his wife is pregnant
remember i told you at the beginning i
was expecting a fair child his wife was
pregnant
wow yeah how did he kill her um
suffocated suffocate her jesus christ
but he lied and said
they had an argument and he was
strangling her whatever and she just
laid there and took it
that's what he said to the police at
first but it was clear that he
suffocated her in asleep because
um the father said i know my daughter
she would have [ __ ] fought him
there was no scratches nothing
everything was perfect suffocated
they're going to sleep
jesus christ fam this is what i said to
you yesterday uh the other day
premeditated murder and stuff like that
i don't know how these men do it it's a
scary concept because like even like
when i say
once i said like um like child molesters
and stuff like that then man don't last
in pen
oh yeah they won't they don't last in
pen but if i'm if i'm if i'm in pen
right
and let's say i'm top dogging pen and
i'm just i'm just a mean [ __ ]
yeah
if a pedophile gets sent in my in my
cell and they're like oh
donnie's in james's cell he ain't gonna
make it through the week yeah
and i'm thinking i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy
up i'm thinking i'm gonna [ __ ] the child
molester i'm gonna [ __ ]
this guy up yeah fam like
if he's being nice to me yeah i i can't
find it
to just kill him yeah he has to do
something where i'm like
cool like even if he
hit like obviously for me to kill
someone
they'd have to go they'd have to do
something crazy yeah
for me to kill a pedophile while i'm
already in prison you don't have to do
much yeah he has to do something yeah
he has to do something to get a rise out
of me to do something i can't just you
don't need to
yeah i'm just chilling in the bed yeah
and he's asking me if i want
pot noodles in that i mean he's like i'm
going this way do you want anything
yeah yeah yeah i'm like i'm good bro
thanks and i'm thinking he can't do that
for me to be like
when he's asleep tonight i've got a
murderer he's going to nancy when he's
next yeah
because especially when i don't know
anyone that he's done too
he's not done anything directly to me
yeah he's obviously [ __ ] kids and all
this horrible horrible [ __ ]
i didn't see him do it i don't know any
of the kids that he did it too this is
just hearsay and he's a nice guy
he's a nice guy he's a nice guy you're a
cell mate he's so he's a nice he's
marceli and he's fine he offers me [ __ ]
all the time we play cards
he's dope at jenga and it's just like he
he has funny anecdotes
jeremy's an intelligent well-read guy i
was supposed to kill him in the sleep
do something to me i mean like kick the
like it
shake the bed at night or something you
know what i mean do something to piss me
off with me yeah like
keep fighting in my face or say do
something bro
where i'm like big man stop and he said
shut the [ __ ] up then you're dead now
that's all you needed to do because
you're beautiful but don't just be
don't don't to be a nice guy i don't
know how because when was watching was
it yours was watching the team
what the other day where donnie said he
killed um
a prison thing where donnie donnie um is
that i'm a killer that's a trailer it's
a trailer i'm a killer okay okay
was that the apartment jason popped me
up today and it was on netflix and the
the thing
he said he just climbs down from his
bunk he says he was like yeah he was a
child minister just calmed down from a
bunk when he's asleep and just strangled
him
where was your motivation where did you
find it in here to
to go into he's already impending so
he's like [ __ ] yeah that's probably it
that's what i think that your men your
mentality will obviously change when
you're in pen
especially if you've been a fears i'm
assuming i guess so bro
scary especially if you're there for
life especially if you're on death row
like you've got nothing to lose but yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah nothing to do with true
someone else and people on death rows
you don't die the next day they die of
like 10 15 20. oh they die
years later what's the point i'm
thinking
is that many people how can there be
that many people on death row
that it takes you 20 years to kill
someone that got convicted that's only
five years bro it's apparently
i looked into it because when i was
watching i'm either killer i am a killer
so many people were just on death row
for years and years so i looked into it
thinking
all right what what's going on yeah why
are they on death row before yeah what
what what's the long thing are they just
killing people every day that's what i
was thinking
i forgot that many people no there is a
minimum sentence that you have to be on
death row for
because some is it's the legality
there's legal requirements that you have
to be on death row for a certain amount
of time
to you have to basically you have to go
through your appeal process
you have an appeal process so let's say
you can appeal three times you can only
appeal three times over the span
of let's say 15 years okay so you have
to spend 15 years
in prison so you've wait you've used all
your appeals
and now you can get killed that's why it
takes so long
oh and it used to be back in the day
apparently it used to be like eight
years
now it's like 15 20 years okay i'll say
rap if i've done it and i know i'm not
getting appealed
yeah fine kill me now injection thing
asap no i'm done put me to the front of
the cube
just kill me now what so i can suffer a
pen for 20 years and then kill me
because i've i've i've lost all
connection to the crime after 20 years
you know i mean yeah
20 years later you'll feel like big man
i'm i've changed 10 years later you're a
different person that's the thing as
well that's um
good with the nightstalker he died of
cancer in there in it after 20 years
he was in there for 20 years and he died
of cancer and then i remember one woman
was like
sounds like an easy way out to me is it
is it sorry to
circle back with the nightstalker
obviously i think it was an episode
three
they discussed what his upbringing was
and like his parents and all the [ __ ]
bro for a little second you felt sorry
for him
his dad used to take him to a graveyard
and time to a gravestone and leave them
with
gravestones overnight even they're
overnight bro that will make you do
anything to anyone
bro you one night at that i'll tell you
now i'm a night [ __ ]
i'm a nightstalker tab if i'm a kid
and my dad picks me up in the middle of
the night takes me to a graveyard
and ties me to a gravestone and leaves
me there all night was it gravestone was
a cross
oh i i don't know it was one of them but
was in the cemetery it was in the
cemetery i know that
if it was a cross that's [ __ ] up it
probably was a cross
that's not right bro that would do that
would do stuff to anyone it actually
made me feel a little bit sorry
it has to it was mad it has to he killed
well he attacked so many people
so many people he didn't give [ __ ] he
didn't care when
how did he choose these man he just
decided just pick them off at random
that's scary man was raping old women
fam that the two sisters the
eight-year-old some sisters
lived in the same yard and he bludgeoned
one of them to bludgeon both of them
oh nah man nah
nah he's sick bro
and you know did you hear that um you
know the one he killed you know the one
i told you
where she caught the butler with the
keys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
said the yet that he killed in there
she didn't know he was there she was she
had a house on the table she was reading
something on the thing and he waited
there
until she looked up so she can see the
fear in his eyes oh
yeah just like what you saw in that dog
just then doug was waiting on the stairs
you man don't get it you man
don't get all right i'm gonna paint the
picture me and jimmy
come into the studio us dude our um our
room is on the second floor so we have
to go a couple of stairs couple stairs
and then for some reason there's just a
dog
there's just a [ __ ] dog at the top of
the staircase i'm just like it's quiet
it's empty
obviously it's gone what six o'clock you
don't expect anyone to be in the in the
whole building so you walk in now
walking up the stairs and there's just a
fluffy
wretched looking dog just there the lead
is off him the least yeah the lead's on
the front is on the floor
and it looks like he's protecting
something i saw
him my heart left my chest i turned to
james
and i grabbed his wrist i was thinking
fam
what is this what is this because he
hadn't seen it he was like
what what what yeah he just turned the
corner i was like
oh my god he was like what is this dog
it didn't make sense
some the dog didn't make he didn't bark
he didn't move he just stared at me and
i was like oh
my god it could have like it's just as
scary as if you turned and just saw a
clown standing there
imagine that i would have screamed
you come into the office no one's in the
building
you're walking up the stairs because the
dog's waiting at the the top of the
stairs of the stairs
there's nothing like he's looking he's
looking he wasn't like
he was ready for us to come up the
stairs he wasn't like he wasn't over
here
yeah and then turned his neck to see us
he was waiting here he heard us he heard
us coming up the stairs
was this so it's literally as far as i'm
concerned it's literally the same as if
i walked up there
and just there's a clown standing there
staring at me staring but that i would
have dipped
i would have i did i would have done
brother that's what i said to
my man he's so lucky that it was you're
so lucky that it was you that saw the
dog and not me
because i would have made it the dog
would have chased us yeah i know 100
percent of the dog would have changed
you would have made a c
i would have dropped everything launched
you everything to save myself
anything to save myself from just
reaction
just reaction either that or i would
have done exactly what i said
and i would have froze yeah and when it
made a move
as soon as the dog just nicked his neck
or anything i would have
dipped i'm so happy that you saw it
because you dissolved all fear from me
by the time you'd froze yeah then turn
back
and then looked at it again and then i
saw your body relax and then i looked
and saw a dog there
i saw a bit i was more just like what
the [ __ ] yeah i wasn't scared though
because of you i already seen you go
through it
but if it was me the fear that ran
through my body
i bet your blood went cold cold
james i wish someone could have zoomed
into my eyes
my pupils would have dilated that would
have made the best thumbnail boy
wow i wish i saw it oh god but yeah um
anyway let's do it with my [ __ ] that
was that was funny bro
oh jesus christ
oh got my stomach's
rumbling i'm starving
okay okay okay i read this one
and it's a bit
[Music]
uh how do i say
it's not safe for work yeah it's just a
bit like
wow i haven't read it properly yeah but
i've seen like the little bits of bobs
of it and i'm just like oh man um
i'm gonna try and keep it safe for
youtube as well okay so i might just
like use different words of what my own
energy is yeah yeah yeah yeah cool so
massive wagon gents
big fan of the pod uh you might keep
doing your thing
uh so am i the [ __ ] i'm gonna
i'm gonna cut straight to it my girl's
head game is absolutely atrocious
that's it i'm gonna cut straight to it
girl's head game is absolutely atrocious
it's honestly so bad to the point where
i specifically asked her
not to do it anymore oh my god
bro it's one of them ones where
her teeth be grinded on the shaft found
oh my god
okay he said the experience is just very
unpleasant i i've had that
i've had that i've had that that cheese
grater ting we've all had oh we've all
had that sorry g
um so yeah this obviously uh effects
uh affects the sex life uh as now for
the past week i haven't
uh been able to to not uh whilst we're
doing a thing
um now here's where it gets interesting
for my birthday a couple weeks ago we
had a three waiting
with her best friend oh fab the amount
of three ways we've had
on this pod over the last six weeks or
so it's crazy
it is crazy do i live in a ditch
we live in a different we live in a
parallel universe this dawn's from south
africa
we've already had the discussion shit's
different in south africa yeah
it's different over there it is
different over there um so yeah
free with your best friend uh and he
said the best friend is
so effing hot
and she gave me the best experience of
my life
wow wow indeed well indeed well there's
so many pinpoints here
it's ridiculous um man said during she
gave me the gawk gork
900 sloppiest of the sloppy toppy
oh my that is the sloppiest of the
sloppy chocolate
that's here that's i don't get any
better fam that is
that's drip bubbles bubble galore bro
oh my um man said that beautiful specif
specimen of a woman really deserves an
award for her performance that night
wow these times your girlfriend is just
chilling just cheese grating the thing
well you're in heaven really forgot was
a threesome i completely forgot what was
it oh yeah yeah
the girlfriend's there watching this all
happen vex
livid man said no i'm either asked of
telling my girlfriend that she should
introduce her best friend into our
regular
um sex life so she can teach her and
expand
both of our knowledge big shout out from
south africa by the way as we said at
the end
this is an open and shut case as far as
what i'm saying fam did you
when you were seeing my face on the fam
you know i make these faces
that's an open and shut case yes
without a shadow of a doubt silly
question please do a rerun for that all
right let's go recap
fantastic this is the thing as well a
lot of the time when we
when we get to the easy yes or no's the
input is dead
your input was fantastic so thank you
for the message take the picture
but god yes all right cool so recap
my man chilling with his wife wife
cannot perform acts adequately
and it's got to the point where it's
affected them and their relationship
so much that man can't even know anymore
so
it's his birthday she hollers her best
friend and said let's do it let's just
do a two-man thing on my man and give
him the time of his life
he enjoys the birthday three-way um but
during the best friend
who he thinks is banging for starters
mistake
and gave him the sloppiest of sloppy
tops gal gawk 900 man said
um so from then he had such a fantastic
time that he thought cool this is a good
idea
i'm gonna ask my girlfriend if it's all
right if we bring her in just on a
regular thing
she can teach you stuff that you need to
learn and she can teach me stuff
is that okay and he asked am i the
awesome and i said is that an [ __ ]
thing to do
oh my you must be the prince of south
africa that's all i know you're royalty
yeah because
your mind don't work like a normal
person he's not a normal human being
you're not scared of losing anything he
has no fear
he's the night stalker he has no fear oh
yeah you find it work right you can't
possibly ask us this question and not
think you are an [ __ ]
like did you not read this message back
before you press send
big man simple empathy
how would you like it if
[Laughter]
if you and your homeboy run a train in
your girl and then she turned around
afterwards and said oh last night was
great and you were like yeah gang gang
you're welcome happy birthday
and she was like oh thank you so much by
the way
is it cool if tyrone comes back like
every monday wednesday and thursday
just just just to do the thing again and
you're like what do you mean just to
liven up just to like spice it up a
couple of times
he might teach you a thing or two
imagine hearing that
i'm boxing your head off teach me
something
you want my boys to come through and
teach me stuff oh it's arm's house
regularly not even not even just a
birthday anymore
regular occasions no special occasion
thing should we break it a couple times
a month
regular please wow wow you have no
respect
you have no respect you have no respect
no no no
the fact that as well that you you've
obviously pre-meditated and liked the
best friend as well
so my assumption is that the best friend
must have known that this guy likes him
this guy likes him
because there's no way in hell
me and you for example there's no way in
hell i've got a thing right and i was
like big man come
let's [ __ ] my girl together and then
you're eating her out like say
you've you've never eaten someone out
before do you know what i mean you're
eating around like saying
[ __ ] i've been wishing for this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
i can't get my words out like that what
to me isn't i couldn't see that i'd be
like what's going on it's like
it's too much too firm too intimate you
man done this before
do you know what i mean i thought it was
just a little surprise your girl was
there while
your her best friend was giving you the
best head of your life and she just sat
there and took it what was she doing
she's got nothing left
she's got nothing left and then you have
the audacity to ask her to make this a
regular thing
she should have stabbed you in the
throat she should have stabbed you in
the throat
ah you're an [ __ ] bro
bro that message alone this is the
dreading that message alone
has ruined threesomes for any guy moving
forward now
any girl who listens to this pod who is
contemplating
patterning the threesome for their man
is now not going to do it you're an
awesome bro
that is unbelievable it is unbelievable
fantastic content but terrible terrible
morals from you bro
you should you need to be honest well
it's done i'm assuming the
relationship's done
because if i'm the girl it didn't make
it past that conversation
the relationship must be done because it
couldn't have made it past the
conversation because if she has
any decency left she would have left you
yeah if she has any pride left in her
chest
she has to leave you bro she can't
affirm that and just
be like yes or no that's the thing as
well what happens
she says yes and she wants to kill
herself and she says no
and you might can't go back to normal
because she doesn't know you'll probably
be vex actually
you're fixed and she's vex it's it's a
it's a lose-lose bro
um so i'm glad you had a good birthday
yeah that's the last day that's the last
that's the last birthday of your life g
that's that's an opener shuck but yeah
let's wrap it up on that
um disgraceful note but thank you for
the message though because it was great
all right see you man next week
[Music]